you don't have to finance or lease a car
to save money instead why not buy a car
for 10 grand and drive it into the
ground you might even be able to sell it
for the same amount in three years
meaning you drove it for free the entire
time that's what I ended up doing when I
was starting out and even though at the
time I was a cash millionaire in my bank
account I drove a Prius with a dent in
the side door and a crack in the
windshield and someone actually saw me
at an event that I was presenting at and
they were like wait I thought we were
supposed to be rich and I said shouldn't
judge me on my car you should judge me
on my bank account